Seitenklapper, Seitenklapper gehalten mit gerader Ausflug.
Beim Seitenklapper, also unsere Schirme können klappen nach wie vor, ist es so, wenn wir eine Seite einklappen, dann bremst das den Schirm, also erinnert euch beim Ohrenanlegen, alles was klappt bremst, in dem Fall bremst das die rechte Seite ziemlich ab und es würde eigentlich eine Bewegung nach rechts resultieren.
Also der Schirm würde gerne Dynamik nach rechts herum aufbauen, wir wollen das nicht.
Wir wollen gerade fliegen mit jeglicher Störung, immer versuchen gerade zu fliegen, gerade irgendwo reindonnern ist wesentlich weniger schlimm als mit Drehbewegung, weil wir da dann deutlich höhere Sinkwerte haben.
Also immer probieren das Drehen zu verhindern.
Bedeutet für uns als Reaktion, wenn der Schirm einseitig einklappt, in der Realität, dann dreht er dann in der Regel auch auf die Seite ab und dann wollen wir das mit der Gegenbremse verlangsamen.
Warum nur mit der Gegenbremse?
Erkläre ich euch sofort.
In der Theorie ist es so, ihr müsst das auch ankreuzen, wenn die Frage kommt bei der Flugpraxis, den Seitenklapper stabilisieren, müsst ihr zusätzlich das Körpergewicht auf diese offene Seite legen und damit ein bisschen weniger bremsen.
Aber in der Praxis ist es so, bei einem 50% Klapper funktioniert das vielleicht noch, bei 60-70%, was ja dann wirklich für uns eher das Problem ist.
Dann funktioniert das nicht mehr.
Das heißt, ihr habt so viel Last am rechten Tragegurt weg, das schafft ihr gar nicht auf die linke Seite rüberzulegen und es ist nicht einmal förderlich.
Wenn wir das Gewicht fallen lassen auf die geklappte Seite, dann wird der Tragegurt zuallererst auf der hinteren Ebene wieder belastet.
Das bedeutet, wir verhelfen den Schirm viel eher zum Wiederöffnen.
Also fallen lassen, das könnt ihr euch auch merken für die Fliegerei.
Wenn wir das Körpergewicht fallen lassen, ist immer gut, ihr belastet immer genau die Seite, die gerade belastet werden muss.
Ein Akkupilot macht das zum Beispiel.
Der lässt seinen Körper eigentlich immer fallen auf die Seite, die gerade belastet werden muss.
Und deshalb machen wir das auch.
Gut, wie können wir das Ganze fliegen?
Wichtig ist natürlich, dass wir probieren, diese 40-50% Fläche einzuklappen.
Und das schaffen wir, indem wir zum allerersten Mal auf der Klappseite die Bremse am Druckknopf fixieren.
Oder magnetisch.
Nicht wie bei mir, das ist egal.
Oder ihr lasst sie einfach los, aber ja nicht in der Hand behalten.
Weil wenn wir jetzt die A-Gurte ziehen und die Bremse in der Hand haben, ziehen wir die Bremse vielleicht das Müh mit.
Und dann weiß der Schirm nicht so recht, was soll er tun.
Soll er einklappen oder soll er wieder öffnen?
Deshalb lassen wir die Bremse weg.
Fixieren sie am besten, dann macht sie am wenigsten Chaos.
Die andere Bremse bleibt ungewickelt, aber ganz oben am Steg in der Hand.
Da könnt ihr euch auch, wenn ihr wollt, ein bisschen anpassen.
Am Trageburt abstützen, dass die Hand da nicht irgendwo ins Juhet weghaut.
Also so leicht am Trageburt abstützen.
Nie am Trageburt festhalten, sondern immer nur so abstützen.
Gut, dann kommt er vielleicht auch ein bisschen nach vorne.
Es ist wichtig, dass ihr auf jeden Fall über die Leinenschlösser kommt, aller A-Leinen.
Das heißt auch diese Ohrenanleghilfe, die müsst ihr auch mitnehmen.
Also alle A-Leinen, die ihr habt, mitnehmen.
Oberhalb der Leinenschlösser.
So packen mit dem kleinen Finger nach oben und Zeigefinger und Daumen umfassen das Leinenschloss.
So oberhalb des Leinenschlosses.
Und dann könnt ihr ziehen.
Am Anfang zieht ihr mal etwas langsamer.
Dann die A-Leinen fixieren, weil sonst haut es die euch gerade wieder rauf.
Also ziehen und dort, wo ihr das gerade habt, könnt ihr euch am Haupttrageburt festhalten.
Und jetzt vorsichtig mit der linken Bremse arbeiten.
Ganz gefühlvoll Flucht suchen, geradeaus Flucht suchen.
Und dann mit dem geradeaus-Flug einfach mal 3 Sekunden so weiter fliegen.
Das ist nicht unbedingt so, dass ihr die Bremse zieht und dann dort behalten könnt, sondern da müsst ihr vielleicht ein bisschen arbeiten.
Darum ist diese Flucht suchen auch so wichtig.
Einen fixen Punkt im Gelände zum Schirm schauen, nach vorne schauen, ah ja, jetzt fliege ich geradeaus, wunderbar.
Jetzt kommt das Kommando von mir, Klapper lösen, ok, dann geht die rechte Hand, also die Klappseite, einfach mal nach oben.
Die linke Hand sucht weiter den geradeaus-Flug.
Bis der Klapper draußen ist und dann kann die Gegenbremse einfach nach oben freigehen.
Auf gar keinen Fall einfach alles loslassen, weil wenn der Klapper drinnen bleibt, dann drehen wir nach rechts auf die geklappte Seite ab, das wollen wir nicht.
Also darum die Gegenseite einfach stabilisieren, bis der Klapper draußen ist.
Wenn der jetzt nicht von alleine raus geht, dann holen wir uns die Bremse, nehmen die Bremse und pumpen einmal.
Zack, bang, ja, immer noch geradeaus-Flug.
Visualisieren, schauen, wo geht es hin, alles klar.
Schirm ist immer noch nicht offen, 21, 22, bang, ich gebe ihm nochmal eine, oder?
Dann ist er offen.
Und wenn nicht, nochmal einen Pumpen.
Aber immer in so zwei, drei Sekunden abstimmen.
Und wenn das der Fall ist, der Schirm offen ist, dann können wir mit beiden Händen wieder ganz hoch, beziehungsweise mit der Außenhand ganz hoch.
Jetzt, warum mit der Gegenbremse so vorsichtig arbeiten?
Wir haben einen sehr, sehr kurzen Steuerweg.
Wir haben 50% Fläche, die wegfällt.
Das heißt, wir haben nur noch 50% Fläche, die wegfällt.
Erinnert euch, Flächenbelastung steigt enorm an.
Und mit der Flächenbelastung steigt auch der Steuerpunkt an.
Das bedeutet, wir haben den Steuerpunkt viel eher erreicht.
Also Steuerweg ist deutlich kürzer geworden.
Und der Druck im Schirm, also gerade auf der noch offenen Seite, auf der Bremse, der ist enorm hoch.
Das heißt, auch der Steuerdruck ist höher geworden.
Also man muss wirklich feinfühlig fliegen, ganz feinfühlig den geradeaus-Flug suchen.
Und das Ganze natürlich ein paar Mal trainieren.
Einmal links, einmal rechts, dass man sich da nicht zu fest drauf fokussiert.
Wenn wir jetzt zu wenig Fläche reinbekommen haben beim Seitenklapper, dann dürft ihr nochmal dran gehen.
Also lasst dann los, sage ich auch, lasst nochmal los, geht nochmal dran.
Dann müsst ihr versuchen, ein bisschen aggressiver zu ziehen.
Also wir müssen 50%, sollte man hinbekommen.
Wir dürfen auch mal in der Schulung gut 60% fliegen oder mal 70%, je nachdem, wenn wir gut die Höhe haben.
Aber wichtig ist, wenn wir jetzt wirklich zu wenig haben und es ist so bei 40%, dann sage ich zu euch, ziehe ein bisschen aggressiver.
Also dann dürft ihr nochmal hingehen, ein bisschen aggressiver ziehen.
Vielleicht zieht ihr dann auch noch ein bisschen tiefer.
Und der Schirm legt sich auch vom Klappen her viel besser nach hinten weg.
Und dann wieder genau das Gleiche, vorsichtig gegensteuern.
Einfach nur so weit, dass er geradeaus fliegt und den geradeaus-Flug behalten, bis sich das Commandergeber klapperlässt.
Und dann wieder, wie gesagt, zuerst den klapperlässt.
Dann lösen und dann die Bremse, wenn der Schirm auf.
Gut, einfach das zum Klappen.
Einmal rechts, einmal links.
Immer dran denken, auf der Klappseite vorher die Bremse fixieren.
Wer das nicht macht und den Klapper so runterzieht, der wird sehen, der Schirm wird sich nicht sehr gut klappen lassen.
Man braucht da wirklich die Bremse frei, also gar nicht mit in der Hand behalten.
Gut, okay.